um today i'm going to be talking about
low risk
volume based order flow trading
strategies you know
one of the great things about investor
expos is they have such a wide range
of speakers you know the the last
speaker
uh mr thomas you know he's more of a
long-term view of the market
i have a very short term i have an
intraday view of the market you know
there is just so many different ways to
approach the market
and is you know people always ask you
know
what's the best way to approach the
market well you know you have to find
the way that's most suitable for you
and today i'll be talking about using
volume in your trading and i'll teach
you specifically how to
identify volume behavior how to turn
volume into value how to value the
market i'm going to talk about
three low risk volume based trade setups
now what i'm going to show you today is
how to look at
the value area the volume on a micro
level as low as bar by bar
and what makes value so useful is it's
based on a perception of fairness
you know you as a trader you should
always be asking is
the market trading a fair price where
participants
are happy to transact and which
basically begs the question
is the market trading at value you know
if the market is not trading at value
then it's going to start moving and
why order flow right because i'll be
talking about it volume and value
in context of order flow well order flow
gets you as close to what's happening
right now in the market you know it's
one thing
like i said earlier right you know
there's different types of traders
there's long-term traders
and there's very short-term traders i
categorize myself as a
short-term trader and intra-day trader
as opposed to
someone that's willing to um you know
buy a stock and hold it for
six months you know through covid
through the election anything like that
you know it's
i find that could give you a lot of
sleepless nights you know my
my nephew goes to wake forest and you
know he's interested in stocks and
when the stocks are up he doesn't you
know we don't really chat much online
but when the stocks are down
um you know it's oh my gosh what should
i do you know that's the difference in
trading styles right i
i look at very short-term trading by the
end of the day
win or lose that day is gone right i
don't have to carry it with me overnight
into bed staring at the ceiling over you
know is this position a good position or
not
and with order flow that allows you to
get
right up next to what's trading in the
market right now
and the second reason is once you
understand how the current trading
activity is impacting the market and how
it causes
the market to move you're going to
understand the market better
right we all want to understand the
market what's going on in the market
and by looking at the volume and by
understanding what's happening in the
order flow
you're going to have a grasp on why the
market is moving
right now and lastly orderful gives you
an edge over other traders because
you're going to see things they're not
seeing right that's
that's a big edge you know it's like
playing cards and be able to see
you know the the person you're playing
against be able to see what
uh you know what cards they're holding
and best of all i'm going to show you
how you can do this without
past trading experience you know i've
got a lot of trading experience
but you know what i'm going to show you
comes from that experience
you're going to be able to do this
without having to use mathematical
formulas
without complicated technical analysis
without macro fundamental analysis you
know oh my gosh you know
now you know potentially we have a new
president how's that going to affect the
market you know you don't have to worry
about that stuff
um you know without algorithmic trading
tools you know everyone always says oh
you know the algos are out there to get
you
um yeah you know that's another that's
another
several hour long conversation and i'm
gonna teach you how to do it without
programming skills you know nowadays
you know it's interesting to be a trader
now you know if you if you go look at
you know the job postings anywhere for
you know hedge funds
or you know banks you know
required you know you got to have
programming background you know most of
us
you know we don't have that skill and
you don't necessarily need that skill
to become a trader now this morning it
was very fascinating
in the gold market right that's why i
get excited about order flow right
you know gold was trading um you know
hit just about
1950 this morning around 9 25 came off
right came off to the 1943 42 and a half
area
bounced up as you can see here right we
got that big candle you know all the
candlestick guys oh that's that's uh
bullish hammer you know market went up
but what was interesting
okay this was fascinating the market
came down in this bar
stopped then reversed and went up and
made new highs you know as a trader
you know this is why i love order flow
so much is because
i can see why i understand why the
market came back to
this level right in this box why it came
down to this level
stopped and then started going up again
right and in the overflow this is just a
normal volume footprint chart
okay and you know if you're looking at
a normal volume footprint chart most
likely you can understand why right it
came down to
the point of control which is right here
in this bar this um
gray rectangle right the low of this red
bar
literally touched that level and rallied
up
but what i'm going to show you is today
in this presentation
by the time you walk away you're going
to understand why these two bars
not just this bar here but even this bar
why they come down to
this level right which is an area
in this bar and then started to reverse
up okay
so for those of you that are new to one
of my presentations just quick about me
i've got over 25 years professional
trading experience i started on the cme
floor with dean whitter reynolds i left
the floor when electronic trading
started
taking off and i worked on the upstairs
trading desk at dean witter
trading globex which is the cme project
a which was
the board of trade nymex access which
was the
um nymex comex trading system as well as
all the other markets around the world
it was a big eye opener you know when
you're on the trading floor i was in the
the currency quadrant in front of the
swiss franc and deutsche mark pitt you
know and occasionally i'd go to the
japanese yen and british pound
um section on the other side of the
floor and people be like wow you watch
four markets you know you're
you must know a lot of stuff well not
really when you're on the trading floor
you're very focused on that one market
but coming off the trading floor it
really opened up a big world for me as i
was
all of a sudden exposed to eurex to life
to
cymex tokyo all these other markets
after
dean witter i left to join edf man which
is a big english trading firm
that's um you know over 250 years old
after edf man i joined commerce bank in
chicago as a licensed urex trader
um with the exchange but i was trading
in chicago so that would mean
trading euros out of chicago you know
the market would open at 1 am so i would
come in at 10 a.m
catch sort of the the second half of
asia
and then um you know all day into europe
after that i joined cargill and i
was the head of the futures trading desk
in chicago and they sent me out to
singapore to set up a trading desk when
the exchange in singapore was closing
which i did after that i joined jp
morgan i spent eight years at
morgan in singapore as vice president of
futures trading
okay after jp morgan i left when my
daughter was born
and you know i wanted to spend more time
with my family because i realized that i
can't spend
eight hours i'm sorry like 12 hours a
day outside of the house basically i was
going in the office at
five i was in the office ready to go at
5 30 in the morning
until about 5 o'clock at night i
couldn't do that forever
especially after you got a newborn right
you that's not the life that you want
so i left jp morgan right i left a nice
paying job
and security to do my own thing right
i started writing a book on trading and
trading for myself now this presentation
is not about me right it's about showing
you how order flow
is going to improve your trading results
quickly you know a lot of people think
oh yeah i'm going to just sit down um
you know start trading and it's going to
be a nice straight line
up i'm going to start making money
instantly well what it really looks like
is this very squiggly line
it's you know you're all over the place
you know you start out
move backwards go up come down if that's
just the reality of trading and
oftentimes
the reality of life so if you stay to
the end i'll show you how to get a copy
of my book that i just explained that i
started writing
after i left jp morgan on trading order
flow you know there's
no books on trading order flow that's
why i wrote one because
i have a lot of experience up to that
point in 2013
with order flow and there was just
nothing available on the market
um you know for traders to to understand
you know it was sort of this vague
thing you know order flow you know the
whole jesse livermore
reminiscence of stock operated he was an
order flow trader you know there's a lot
of great quotes in there but doesn't
really get into the nitty-gritty that's
what my book is
right so i'll teach you how to get that
and one last thing the charts that i use
in this presentation are generated from
the order flow software that i
um created right on order flows.com
but what i'm showing you today if you
have another software you can
apply what i'm talking about today but
without
me explaining it to you you're not going
to know what to look for that's why i'm
doing this presentation so
you know it can help you in your
analysis and become a better trader
so you know just the disclaimer
self-explanatory
all right so identifying volume behavior
so you're not trading blind
all right so as a trader we've all
looked at charts and see the market
comes back to a certain level
then it re keeps going up in its
original direction
and this was crude oil simple one min
sorry five minute chart right you see
the market hit the low of the day
rallied up
came off to a certain level and then
rallied up from there
all right well why did it stop at this
level why didn't it come down and test
the low
or why didn't you know just sort of keep
going up why this particular level
right you know as a trader you know i'm
sure you've all sat there and wondered
oh you know if i could just figure out
why this market you know stops at a
level
and then it keeps going on will people
say well there was support here well
yeah you mean you know it's hard to say
that definitively
as the market is coming down here it's
one thing to look at it after the fact
you know the low of the day is down here
at 21. we're about
15 points higher right now 15 cents
higher
and that's where volume comes in right
if you're looking at a normal bar chart
you don't see
volume you just see price right volume
is the most
underrated market variable that's used
by traders
and if you know how to analyze it and
interpret it you'll be able to see
market turning points develop and
anticipate pullbacks
right like you have here this pullback
and market trends
right so this is that crude oil chart
right here this is that box where we
pulled back to well
it's related to this right right in here
all this stuff that was going sideways
you know it's not pulling back to the
low of the day it's
not a half back you know it's not a 50
retracement
but why well it's because it's related
to the volume now
if you look at the order flow right you
can see
points of controls sort of lining up
at 35 37. now i'm not getting into the
minutia
of order flow in this presentation i'm
assuming most of you guys have some
background in order flow right
so i'm not going to be talking about
delta imbalances or points of control
right so when i say point of control
that's the area in this bar with the
most volume
okay simple okay every bar has one but
you can see it's sort of lining up in
here
yeah you can sort of make that guess
that yeah you know there's probably
support but how do you know it's support
how do you know it's resistance right
well obviously it's going to be support
if we rally up and we come back down to
it but
you know for a lot of traders sort of
identifying that
is you know it's a bit tricky because
you know they just see these point of
controls in every bar and they think
yeah
you know is that important or not but it
is right
and analyzing the volume that you see on
the bid and the volume on the offer
that traded you can see where
institutions are building up a position
or distributing one
transacted volume is what's going to
help you
see how fast the market is moving so we
got a market that's moving sideways
right and we got heavy volume sort of
coming in around this 35
37 35 36 area okay so that's important
to note
right but who wants to spend all day
looking at numbers and trying to put it
in context right you know
you'll go you know that's too difficult
right there's got to be an easier way
and there is
right there is you look at the value
area for a bar now value area
the term value area is is a phrase most
traders are familiar with
right and if you can break it down on a
bar by bar basis
right you could understand where value
is forming
over time right that's how you determine
value where the market is trading
over time if a market is you know this
is a five minute crude oil chart if from
12 20 until one o'clock basically the
market is trading around 35
35 the value areas even though market
goes up and down
right the value areas are sort of
forming around the 35 35 area
that's telling you where value area is
that's telling you where
support or resistance could be now the
value area is a primary component
that's derived from market profile
analysis right and it shows you the
range of prices that reflect the most
interest
on the part of buyers or sellers
most traders analyze the value area on a
day-by-day basis
what i'm telling you right now is to
look at value
area on a bar by bar basis okay and
people say mike
you're crazy value area on a bar by bar
basis
well that's how you turn volume
into value right volume is a data point
right there's a lot of software out
there you know people post these charts
every day
up on twitter or on facebook
the volume profile for the day right and
what are you really keen on in
volume profile right well most important
thing you're looking at is the value
area second thing
is by the point of control where the
market's trading in relation to the
value area
where is trading in relation to the
previous
bar or in this case previous day because
most people are sort of taught to look
at it on a day-by-day basis
now the value area in market profile or
volume profile terms
is where 70 of the day's business is
conducted which is basically one
standard deviation
okay yeah i understand you know for a
lot of you guys you think it's 68
for the standard deviation 70 is
is good enough for me there's always
price and value but they're not always
the same
okay so seeing the value area
right in a bar where the volume is trend
where
the most volume in the bar is
transacting not the most volume rather
or 70 percent of the volume is
transacting
is going to help you understand where
we're trading
in that bar relative to current value
and as well as
where we are relative to where value was
on the bar before now again how is that
different than looking on a daily chart
you know the daily profile and and doing
that same analysis you're just taking it
a step down and
the reason why value
is important is because it's where trade
is being facilitated
okay where trade is not being
facilitated where it's difficult for a
big buyer or a big seller you know a big
buyer to buy or a big seller to sell
that's going to be an unfair value now
again you know here's gold this is
yesterday
right you know a lot of these markets
you know i'm going to show you gold i'm
going to show you crude oil today i'm
going to show you
euro currency e-minis it's the same
concepts in different markets you know
and on different time frames five-minute
chart one minute chart
tick chart um range base chart volume
based chart
i don't use a renko chart but uh you
know i'm sure it would apply the same
there
this was yesterday in gold right we got
this nice run up
right you can see running up putting
this big value area
at the swing high and then the bar
closes outside
right we open up above value of the
previous bar
we closed down well below value of the
previous
bar we open up inside value of the
current bar close well outside of value
what do you think the market's going to
do it's rejecting these higher prices up
here obviously
it's rejecting the previous value right
and all of a sudden we're trading lower
and
you know over the next 30 minutes you
got a quick
sell-off of you know from 1906 all the
way down to 1900.
here's gold on a one-minute chart you
know that was a five-minute chart that i
just showed you now we're coming down on
a one-minute chart
okay we come up to the high start to go
sideways right we see value areas
going horizontal right we've got value
value value breaks a little bit value
value value
comes up potentially going to go back in
you know go back
up or not well where do we trade we
trade back into that value area from
earlier right this area where you got
these three value areas sort of lined up
around the 1934 area this bar comes up
back into that 1934 area
hangs on there then the next bar opens
up we close outside that value area
so you know then just hang around go
sideways sort of test that value area
again the value area from earlier
rejects it
starts trading lower and then finally
breaks right so you can see how
we're coming back up into this value
area right in here this
on a one minute chart we're forming this
value area
not at the high of the day just off the
high of the day
and every time we come back in it we
reject those prices
and the market what do you think the
market's going to do if you come back
into the value area
then come out come back in come out and
then finally
you know it's pretty self-explanatory
now this is
e-mini's it's a one-minute chart you
know value here this is
where we talk about being on the right
side of the market at all times now this
is where value area is going to help
traders right you can just see how
value area keeps migrating higher every
single bar now
granted this this is this morning at 3
30 in the morning
whether you're trading you know in the
middle of the night
or asian session or
cash hours you're still going to look at
the same things because
what you're seeing in the value you know
every bar has value whether you look at
a one minute chart or a five minute
chart or whatever
and if you see the value areas going
higher every single bar
you know it doesn't take a rocket
scientist you know after you rally up
from 75 all the way up to 85
yeah we're in a trend well you could
pick it up really quick right we have
this value area forming in here over
one two three bars you start breaking
down then you trade back into that value
area
one two bars and then you break out of
that value area
right that's the go time right and
telling you right
in here around the 3478 3479 area
rather than getting in late you know at
83.84
right that's how value is going to help
you once you start to internalize
the value area and where it is building
you'll go a long way towards staying on
the right side of the market right
and being on the right side of the
market it's going to save you a lot of
money and headaches again you know this
is the value area you can see here this
is a 5 thousand volume chart now
you know i'm showing you different
charts you don't have to keep every
single different type of chart frame
open
but everybody trades their own chart
right
you have to trade a chart you're
comfortable with based on
you know your trading right you know i i
don't i won't look at a 5 000 volume
chart
to trade off of but i'll look at it as a
reference
so you can see here this is yesterday
election day
or so you know the day after election
day um this is the fourth
we got one two three four five six
seven bars basically the value area is
right roughly about the same
right in here yeah it's going sideways
okay then obviously this next bar breaks
down
this value area in this bar here
below any of these previous value areas
right so what do you think is happening
value has shifted now you're out of
balance before you're
in balance now you're out of balance
right it's a lot easier a concept to
understand when you think of terms of
balance
and out of balance right and what
happens the market
again puts in a nice nice sell-off
this is a thousand tick chart similar
thing this was this morning
at uh just before eight o'clock right
and
being on the right side of the market
right obviously value area value or
evaluary value what's value area is
doing
they're going lower right there's no
sense
fighting this you know if this market
pulls back here you got this green bar
you know everyone says well i got all
these red bars i got a green bar should
get long well
why right you should be looking at
what's value what's happening in value
area yeah even though this
this bar is you know it's green starting
to go up but you'll notice as
value is forming in this next bar we're
rejecting this previous bar's value
what do you think is going to happen
well the market sells off from
93 all the way down to the mid-80s
so generally the longer amount of time a
market spends in a value area
the greater the value right the greater
that
area of value is going to be now value
is determined by the market itself
right it's not assigned by some analyst
that says oh there's about
there's value areas here or some trading
gurus levels that he puts out yeah i
think value is here based off this bar
chart well you're not looking at the
volume
how are you going to figure out where
value is
markets determine value through their
rotational process
and this was euro currency this morning
okay market rallied up
right we hit this high 118 69 came off
came back up we put these two wiki
candles in here
all right you got the big wick up the
big wick up
markets rejected sold off from you know
the 50s
down into the 30s you know quick 20 tick
move
okay well why did it just come up to
this level right
it came up here well people say well
that was your earlier high you know it's
become
you know whatever no it's fairly obvious
if you're looking at the value area
right if you're if you're looking at
order flow you can see where this value
is here this area
from just before 7 a.m all the way up to
7 30
that's your value area for this time
period right you don't need to look at
the value area for the entire day
and figure it out if you're looking at
the whole entire day's volume profile i
should have screenshot it
it's not going to give you much
information on why this market just
pulled back right to this level
right and how this is a nice short
opportunity right that you rejected this
level up in here
even the next bar started coming back up
right into that value area
rejected it you know they have these
nice probes up all of a sudden
boom can't go anywhere market sells off
nicely
again this was that gold futures chart i
was showing you earlier right why does
this market
why did this bar pull right down to this
level in here of this bar
earlier you know after this we even went
up obviously made new highs
and if you're just looking at the the
volume footprint chart you know it might
be easy to see say yeah well it came
back to this point of control from
earlier
okay that's a clue
but if you're looking at the value area
it came right into this value here
right even put in on this bar this value
almost overlaps here we rejected this
value from earlier
all right we came back in there stopped
rallied up next bar opens up
we trade into that value area we reject
this bar's value area market moves back
up
right then we rally up to new highs all
right so let's get on to the low risk
training opportunities right that's what
you want to see how to use it in your
trading
and there's a couple of three setups
i'll talk about first one is value area
gaps
uh when a market starts to run momentum
is going to show up
you're going to see a migration of value
right and oftentimes you're going to see
each bar's value area gapping higher
than the previous one now oftentimes we
will fill the gap
but doesn't have to you know it could
just simply be a gap and go move
right we could come in and open up now
on a normal footprint chart or
candlestick chart you know markets can
look choppy
right you just see a bunch of green
candles well market should be going up
right
we've all just tried to analyze the
candles by themselves
you get long then what happens the
market stops and reverses
which isn't very useful right and you
know again you know a lot of people like
to look at the market after the fact and
say oh yeah it was so obvious this
market was going up
you know you can see you know we close
higher we close higher it goes higher
yeah but you know you sort of need a bit
more information
right you want to know where's value
right where's the volume trading
you know is it going higher or is it
going lower
and by looking at the value areas it
opens up a whole other form of analysis
gap analysis right most of us are
familiar with gap analysis
and what it means you know on you know
can we pull back into a gap
but you can see here after we hit the
swing low value area started forming
higher
then a big gap up in the value from the
previous bar
then the next bar another gap up come in
we fill that gap in this bar
and then we gap higher again gap higher
gap higher right as the market's moving
up momentum
when you're starting to see gaps in
the bars in terms of value areas you
know momentum's on your side you know
look at a daily chart of anything you
know stocks
futures or you know bitcoin whatever
when you know that when you start seeing
these gaps
in the bars just by themselves
the market's got momentum and it's
moving but
oftentimes you don't see these gaps if
you're just looking at normal bar charts
right you don't see a gap here right we
you don't see a gap here you don't see a
gap here
but if you're looking at the value all
right so i talk about being able to see
what other traders can't see
you can see there's a gap in value a gap
in value
a gap in value now this is crude oil one
minute chart
previous one i think goes what was that
that was gold now this is crude oil all
right similar thing
gap higher gap higher go sideways
forming some value starts trading up gap
higher
gap higher right so you can see
areas of market momentum
right and you know what was interesting
about this one here
right you have this gap right here you
go sideways you got one two three four
value areas basically at the same level
this bar comes down in here value area
high
of these two bars right stops reverses
goes up
up up up more gaps this is
euro currency okay yeah we're mostly
going sideways in here
but you got a gap here we got another
gap here before the market makes its run
you know and if if you're watching this
in the order flow
you can you can you can see that you
know other traders aren't going to see
that happening
you know basically two gaps right after
the other right that's what you want to
look for
is these these groupings of gaps in the
market
so you can participate in in the move
now this is gold
um this was on election day and
this is what this was very fascinating
you know when you make new highs right
this was a market making new highs
and you're putting in value areas above
the previous high
that's very bullish okay and you can see
you got a gap
a gap a gap but more importantly
you're putting a value area a new value
area above the old high
i mean it's the recent high which was
just made a few minutes ago
then go higher more value being formed
above
the earlier high a new high being formed
more putting in value above the previous
high
you know yeah it's nice that the value
area is coming in
above the previous value area that's
important
but when you're getting into new
territories right new highs of the day
or new lows of the day watch where value
is forming
right as you see here you know this
market when it starts stalling out we're
not putting in
higher value right we're not putting in
higher value anymore
up in here right as the move is stalling
out but if you keep putting in the
higher value
there's more strength to the market and
if you're just looking at a normal bar
chart this is that same chart but a bar
chart here
right this is that chart here you're not
seeing how strong this move higher is
right by putting in
the value at these higher areas right
when you see that value
coming in at these higher levels that
just gives
you a better clue as to the strength of
the move up
now value area builds is the second set
up i'll talk about and i sort of talked
about it a little bit earlier you know
when you got a few bars with value area
sort of bunching up together
and it's when the value starts to expand
horizontally
basically the market is facilitating
two-way trade
at a price level right it's found a fair
price where
people buyers and sellers can transact
with the market
not moving too much okay so for example
this was
yesterday this is a five-minute e-mini
chart
and we've got one two so basically for a
half hour
more or less market is moving sideways
here between 58
and 60 you know 61 and three quarters or
61 even
right in here one two three four bar
five bars value areas
basically overlapping right or as you
can see you know
you have value areas not necessarily
overlapping
over consecutive bars you know
oftentimes the next bar value area will
spill into the previous one
that's a different form of analysis but
this is where it's going horizontally so
this is what happened this is that area
right in here that i was just talking
about
boom we break out of it put in value
area above the previous high
all right that's important to put in
another build coming in here
boom market breaks out higher value area
right that's how you know that this move
had strength
yesterday when we would put in new value
areas
above the the highs you know when we're
making new highs
now this is crude oil okay the same
similar thing you got to build forming
here right you're going horizontal
you're putting in the value area value
value value value value
and then boom it gaps right up here
right and another gap right here
you know but once you put in this value
this build here you know
basically seven minutes forming value
here and then
also in boom the market jumps up you
know you put in other forms of analysis
in terms of imbalance and delta but if
you're just looking at the value area
you know something's a foot already all
right obviously this next bar you got
four imbalances for buying and balances
and
you know we got a quick 30 cent move up
right as we came out of this value area
but the sign
clue was right here as we came out of
this build
we got a gap here obviously the next bar
another gap
that's a good sign as well but by the
time this bar closes
you should be looking and getting along
somewhere in here at 55
and again where would your stop be well
yeah you know you have this
value area this is going to be your
support
so you know this is the area you're
going to be watching you know if the
market pulls back the market could pull
back into
this area and then keep going up
but if it's it starts breaking down
through this area
that's where you're going to be getting
out right you're not being getting out
at a swing low which is
you know 10 15 cents lower you'll be
getting out here that's why i talk about
being as close to the market as possible
right you're finding this bit of
information that's
generated by the market participants
here that
there should be support here if we were
to come back here if we come back here
there's no support
that's where you get out you don't want
let your stop you know 15 cents lower
stop you out
you can get out based on what you're
seeing in the order flow
so another example this is gold this
time right
you got this nice build here forming
over almost
eight nine minutes breaks away here
comes back in tests that area tests that
build rejects it
closes down obviously and works its way
down right it you could be getting in as
quickly as the next bar as you come out
of this build and again the quicker you
get into a position based on how you
read what's happening in the order flow
the tighter your stop is going to be the
tighter your stop is going to be
the lower your risk is going to be you
know you don't have to have a stop up
here at 1905 or something
you know that if this area in here can't
hold
chances are we're going to go higher now
this is nasdaq it's a 30 second chart
okay this was fascinating this is
similar to sort of that
gold chart that happened this morning
this is yesterday now nasdaq on the
order flow right
it gets confusing for a lot of people if
you're trading nasdaq
you know on a longer time frame by a
longer time frame i considered
one minute chart in nasdaq a long time
frame obviously you get these
enormous price swings um you can see
here this is just a 30 second chart
got a range from you know 24 up to 44 in
30 seconds
but what was fascinating about this
pullback
where did it hold it held right where
you had this build
forming one two three four five six
seven bars
right in here came right down to that
level right and it held
so even if you're getting long in here
you know 36
38 you know that if we hold this area in
here where this build is
you're looking pretty good right and the
market immediately snapped back
and rallied like a like a mother
um this is e-mini's yesterday
right 30-second chart as well on the
e-minis you got this nice sideways
activity going on in here
then you got that gap right here right
that's go time
right you got the imbalances as well but
that's telling you that's it's go time
just go ahead get long
you're going to put your stop just on
the other side possibly of this this
area but
if you gap and go forget it you know
we're not even going to retrace back in
there
right that's a nice low risk trade now
the next one i'll talk about is what i
call the eva
right it's uh it's
it's how we use order flow um value
areas
in our order flow software now i've
shown you two ways to use
volume in terms of value in a bar but
honestly it's going to take time for you
to be able to see
through it see it in observation by
getting screen time but and there's
other ways to use value
i just showed you two right there's
there's so many other ways
so let me say you know let the software
help you
you know let the software tell you where
value areas are bullish or bearish
now the order flows trader which is the
software that i that i offer
that i've been um you know the the main
proponent of
for the last five years tells you
where value area is bullish or
bearish okay so again if you're looking
at
a normal volume footprint chart even if
you have value areas drawn on your bars
it can get confusing for a lot of
traders
is this one important or is this one
important i i don't know
um let software highlight that to you
and this is the beauty of of software is
it will do that
right you can have a software tell you
tell me if this is bullish or bearish
that's the whole point of using trading
software do
as a tool to tell you when market
conditions are bullish or bearish
in this case bearish value areas are
going to be highlighted
red bullish ones will be blue and this
is how
this is up to yesterday at two o'clock
202 this is what happened after those
those are those two bearish value areas
and you see the market sold off 10
points
over the next five minutes right that
that's
how useful having software that
highlights this stuff to you is going to
be
here's another example this is on elec
election day all right on a five minute
e-mini chart like i said five-minute
chart 5000 volume chart here here's a
bullish one
all right this is yesterday a nice
bullish one here
actually had another one you know up
here near the high but
this is where you're telling you where
you should be getting along down here at
you know in the 60s 67 68 area
for a nice 10 point move up here's gold
100 tick chart
bearish value area nice move down
so you want to take complex things
and make them simple right and honestly
for a lot of people
they're put off with order flow by
looking at all these numbers
it's daunting i get that when i first
looked at an overflow chart i said what
the hell is this
you know all these numbers and i i
understood what they mean but you know
gosh you know do i really want to sit
there and analyze this stuff and that's
why i created
my company order flows is to take that
information
and highlight this stuff to me on the
chart because i know the value of
looking at volume
what's being traded on the bid what's
being traded on the offer i know the
value
of that information right that's why all
these
hfts you know these hedge funds that's
why they pay big money
to have access to um you know the order
flow
is because it's important right that
they're able to see things that other
traders
aren't seeing you everyone all these
algos are out to get you well all
they're doing is analyzing the order
flow
right and making good decisions off that
so in the past 40 minutes hopefully
you'll agree it's time well spent
honestly i can't cover
everything in a 40 to 60 minute training
session but i got a special offer
so you get everything you need to know
about order flow and in fact
today i'll give you a very special deal
and what it is it's the order flows
trader 3.0 for ninjatrader 8. my
software
runs on ninjatrader everybody okay
that's the software that i use in
trading
i find it to be the most useful the most
easiest to use
you know i'm not a programmer you know i
don't understand you know how to program
stuff i like
the simple to use interface and
ninjatrader is that i have a program
that does all my programming
i like to be able to turn on my computer
fire up a chart
and instantly see things rather than
have to go make all of these adjustments
and the ninjatrader helps me with that
the order flows trader it will run on
the free version or the paid version of
ninjatrader there's two versions it will
run on either one and it's the volume
footprint chart with 17 pre-programmed
order flow
tools and it's easy to set up just takes
a minute or two
and normally i sell it for 8.99 on my
website but
you know you're not going to be paying
8.99 today right
and really the order flows trader is it
takes my knowledge
of trading with order flow and puts it
on the screen for you
you know so you can see what the
institutions are doing but i realize
that having order flow software is one
thing
one thing you still need no to know how
to use it so i don't just give you the
software and say go figure out order
flow on your own
i provide a lot of education on how to
trade order flow
and i have an order flow trading course
normally i sell it for 297 you're gonna
get it for free today i also
have an inner circle video series
there's 56 videos on advanced order flow
training
um you can get it for free and you know
people that want access to this got to
pay
just these videos alone have to pay 497
basically 500 and i'll give you that for
free as well so you can get the software
the training the inner circle video
series
but it's one thing to learn how to
read order flow from videos and books
right
you want to be able to ask me questions
okay and i do
every week for the last two years i do a
live
training session on tuesday nights where
users can join and ask their questions
on order flow
ask me to explain things on you know a
particular market
things that you're struggling with in
your analysis and if you can't attend
the videos are all recorded and you can
watch them
you can see there's 96 videos so far
there's a lot of people that sell
software then sell you training
additionally for what you know you got
software you need to know how to use it
and what to look for
people charge you know a couple hundred
dollars a month just to
you know have you know train you on
their software
you know that's stupid they should be
doing that for free
and i offer that for free so you get my
software training
extra training live training for just a
one-time payment of 749.
go to orderflows.com off three there's
no recurring charges you're not going to
get billed
200 a month or 250 a month no you just
pay a one-time payment 749.
you know we try to keep it low so you
know more traders can access orderful i
think order flow is a great thing
you know it's not like um you know order
flow you know once more people start
reading it
then it's going to diminish the edge no
it's actually in fact it's the opposite
right because once more people
understand what's happening in the order
flow
you know it's going to help the market
move in that direction right so go to
orderflows.com
off 3.html scroll down to the bottom of
the page this is what the page looks
like
it takes you to this button click here
to buy now this is where you get started
you can see what you're going to get
all right it goes to paypal paypal
processes your payment
please note all the information you're
going to get goes to your paypal
registered
email address so whatever email you
enter right in here with paypal
that's where your information is going
to be sent and again it's just a
one-time payment
7.49 so
you're going to get the order flows
trader 3.0 the training course the inner
circle video series
live weekly group training and i got a
special bonus
for investors expo my order flows
playbook as you can see down here
normally i sell it for 297 you're gonna
get that today
for free as a bonus so if you're
interested
in my book on order flows go to
orderflows.combook.html be sure to put
the book.html at the end
to enter your name and email address
click submit it will take you to a page
where you can go and
download the book unfortunately you're
not gonna get a hardcover copy of that
book
but you'll get the book that you can
download and read on your phone on your
tablet
print it out if you want it's up to you
it's it's a lot of information
if you're new to order flow uh it's
going to help you in your trading in
general
go to it so you got to get started
just go to orderflows.com3.html
remember there's no recurring payments
any other payments in the future
you will need to pay your data fees of
course for a live data feed
and you know if you're on a paid version
a ninjatrader
you got to pay for that but it will run
on the free version
of ninjatrader as well if you just want
to use ninjatrader as
your charting platform and enter your
trades through
you know a different platform you know a
broker's platform or your phone some
people like to trade on their phones for
some reasons
so you gotta get started so that's all
go to orderflows.com3.html i think i'm
out of time now anna
um don't have time for questions but
i'll take a look at them
and you know if you got any questions
you always email me mike
orderflows.com and i'll do my best to
get back to you
so thanks anna thank you so much michael
thank you
you're welcome